un admirable édifice gothique et
renaissance financé par la famille de
beille au xvème siècle
aujourd'hui propriété du 7e duc de la
famille de ben la casse en ces termes et
avec un peu plus d'emphase stéphane bern
présentera ce soir us et à la france et
bobby le château privé sera en
concurrence
le temps d'un concours patrimoniale avec
20 autres monuments d'exception comme le
viaduc de millau où la basilique notre
dame de la garde
uc a pour lui une belle histoire de
conte pour enfants je te lécher le
château de la belle au bois dormant
parce qu'il a inspiré charles perrault
et il ya d'élève de charles perrault
racontant son émerveillement devant elle
c'est lors des visites rendues au
marquis de valentine est le propriétaire
de l'époque et il raconte qu'il a été
inspiré par ses toits pointus cette
pierre blanche us et succède à chambord
représentants de notre région pénible
onzième au classement du concours 2014
remporté par le monastère royal de brou
dans ce genre d'épreuve cathodique mon
trésor a fait mieux
deuxième du concours 2015 du village
préféré des français est un plus pour le
tourisme local
+ 30 % de fréquentation en juillet
dernier
c'est tout l'enjeu de ces soirées
orchestrée par la société morgane
productions soirée au cours de laquelle
est rendu public le résultat du vote
populaire et d'un jury de professionnels
du tourisme soirée qui fera l'impasse
sur le magnifique phare du cap ferret en
marge du tournage en juin dernier lors
d'une animation
une jeune fille de 12 ans est morte au
pied du monument girondins